the royals big right-hander brad keller
and his four-seam two-seam slider
combination opponents only hitting 205
versus keller and he has yet to allow a
home run colin moran who came in hot
he's one for seven in the series
in there strike three called and an
excellent first inning for brad keller
chad cole starts for the pirates will be
his ninth appearance his seventh start
to alberto monteci he has been their
hottest hitter switch hitter bats left
strike three called a slider that meant
to be on the inner third uh ended up on
the outer edge franco really has been
clutch of late 10 for his last 22 with
runners in scoring position
hit sharply but off of the third
baseman's glove and here comes
merrifield to home plate the throw is
not in time
boy i'll tell you franco hit that ball
hard and that's a base hit all the way
alex gordon has a chance to really hurt
him and put the pirates behind this is a
big at-bat here for alex
alex pulls it to the right side
bell drops the ball
he will get gordon at first base but he
was going to go home
and the royals take a two-nothing lead
the royals continuing to pressure that's
by putting the ball in play you got to
do that what a great opportunity here
for gutierrez
well that one will get away and the
royals get their third run
and he will score to make it a
four-nothing lead wow
pittsburgh just their defense is falling
apart in this first inning oh man
check this out
oh man that is so dangerous right there
for anyone
no one got a glove on that that's a
straight pitch i don't know what that
was 93 or 94 but man
look at so it kicks off now by the time
they found out what was going on two
runs both runs out there ended up
scoring four runs in heath is the eighth
batter
and with some help from the rookie nicki
who chases it's the final out of a
disastrous top of the first
bell polanco
and reynolds and now the pitch
nikki lopez with a heck of a play to get
him out nikki continues to lead the
major leagues he's plus seven in
defensive run save and he made a
marvelous play from right field that's
right right field is where they're
playing him and he's got to take several
steps i mean he took like 15 steps
on the run like a shortstop would make
in the hole
he's showing his shortstop skills there
at second
he's got to stay on top the ball of sail
if you don't nice play
salvador perez gets into one left center
field and that ball's on goner
five nothing royals
salvador perez a no doubter jumping on
chad cool's first pitch of the third
inning here oh baby belt high it was a
no doubter number five on the season for
salvador perez
who's really been swinging a good bat
since he's come back and he's six for
eleven since coming off the injured list
salvia has two hits and two runs scored
today he struck out heath his first time
up
all four rbi's all the same yep knocks
in a run to make it six nothing
the royals have enjoyed six walks today
and the sixth
will drive in their sixth run and derek
sheldon says i've seen enough and it's
going to go to nick tropiano and field's
still in
good time for nikki lopez to check in
with a hit in this series
ball four second straight batter will
walk with the bases loaded and drive in
a run that makes it seven nothing as
dozier touches home plate wind is walked
twice and might walk for the third time
oh and then he gets a base hit to right
field
and comes one
and comes two
and the royals now have a nine nothing
lead shocked the house they got a hit
with the bases loaded way to go win
perez who started the inning for the
long home run will now come up for the
second time in this inning
base hit right field
lopez is going to be sent home
it's ten-nothing royals as merrifield
makes it to third base
and a three-hit game for salvador perez
struck out only one most of his outs
have been ground outs
got him to hit the ball high in the air
to left gordon on
can of corn for alex brad keller four
shout out
keller to tucker
bounces over to gutierrez bare hands and
throws and that's a heck of a play one
five three oh man if you're if you're
tucker cole tucker you're like man my
case is going pretty bad but i'm not
going that bad right whenever it hits
off the kit the pitcher's foot that is
an automatic base hit especially when
you can run like he does but one hop it
gutierrez with a bare hand he hummed it
over there i mean hum baby
he picked it up and wound up and fired a
rocket
get a clock on that probably was 90 plus
dose of the battery's been on base all
three times
ball is struck well
way back in left and a home run for
hunter dozier 11 nothing royals 442-foot
monster shot by dozier oh man i'm
telling you
that was swung on gone immediately
fastball at 95. just a short compact
swing look at the head position he went
right down had a nice little uppercut
four of course there's no fans out there
to duck
but that was a beauty sixth on the
season only one strikeout
a lot of ground ball outs
done
there's a swing and a miss just his
second strikeout of the afternoon
outstanding baseball
shortstop lopez
two outs
live drive to left olafaris
did he make the catch yes he did and
brad keller has his first
majorly complete game shutout what a
catch
man was that timely that would have
taken his shot away had that ball
falling in there and olivares says hey
look what i came up with and look at the
skipper yeah i love the skipper's
emotions that he shows and brad keller
you were stellar no doubt